so I've been in touch over the last
couple of weeks with some of our viewers
in Hong Kong and one in particular has
been sending me videos videos that have
been taken by others some posted on
social media from Hong Kong some taken
by the viewers family themselves and I
have a video for you today that that is
utterly insane in a despicable sight to
behold and the video is of what appear
to be police on motorcycles running over
protesters at high speed this is not you
know someone's toe caught under a
motorcycle tire in a confusing moment
accidentally or something like that
this is police or what appear to be
police revving up and accelerating at
high speed and hitting protesters of
course viewer discretion is advised
all of that stuff I I know this is very
visual so if you're merely listening to
the podcast or on the radio today you
won't get the full scope but indulge me
for the 28 seconds that we're about to
watch and then I encourage you to find
the video on our YouTube channel
right away
absolutely and utterly insane and things
in Hong Kong just don't appear to be
slowing down at all in fact violence may
be getting worse lawmakers who are
activating for democracy have been
facing arrest police have been using
more and more teargas protestors are
blocking main roads cars are being lit
on fire
a man was actually set on fire a couple
of days ago we heard from a Hong Kong
police Senior Superintendent who said
quote over the past two days our society
has been pushed to the brink of a total
breakdown that can be interpreted in at
least two or three different ways
depending on which side of the protests
you find yourself on here's video of
people being pepper sprayed or tear
gassed at close range this video is
reminiscent of that remember that sick
police officer I think his name was
lieutenant Pike John Pike I believe at
UC Berkeley some years ago just at
point-blank range
spraying almost like you would with with
sunscreen spaying spraying protestors
with teargas this is video from
Bloomberg in Hong Kong
so right now this is this is just
horrible stuff District Council
elections are set for November 24 but
the longer that this goes the more
people are fearing China could get
involved and pressure Hong Kong to
postpone those elections even to go
around Hong Kong's legislature all
together to pass national security
legislation as they're calling it police
shooting a protester that video went
viral the man set on fire I told you
about that video going viral
the man was arguing with protesters he
was some kind of flammable liquid I
don't know if it was alcohol or gasoline
thrown on him and then lit on fire we
have those videos I'm not going to play
them right now but you can easily find
them online if you're so inclined I
genuinely have no idea how this will
settle it's getting uglier and uglier I
would say by the day certainly by the
week and no sign whatsoever of a
de-escalation anytime soon so that's my
question to you if you think ahead a
week a month six months however long
what do you see as even having the
potential to de-escalate circumstances I
don't know the answer I want to hear
from you leave a reply if you're
watching on YouTube or send me a tweet
at de Pakman if you are watching or
listening elsewhere